hours after waves of russian missiles
pounded a military training base on
ukraine's border with poland the u.s
struck back pledging more weapons to
help ukrainian fighters defend their
country
we are determined and the ukrainians are
determined to ensure that anti-tank
anti-armor anti-air capabilities
ammunition
and other forms of assistance actually
do make it to the front to blunt the
russian advance
ukraine is pleading with the u.s and its
allies almost hourly for more military
power
what we are asking is very simple thing
we say army ukraine and we will do the
rest
give us all the weapons necessary and we
will fight for our own land and for our
people the russian attack followed
threats by the kremlin to target foreign
weapons shipments in poland headed to
ukraine the white house still says it
will not put u.s soldiers on the ground
or military jets in the sky above
fearing a broader war with nuclear-armed
russia ukrainian officials already fear
vladimir putin could resort to using
nuclear weapons putin so can he can use
nuclear weapon because if he bombed and
killed russian troops on peaceful cities
children a woman they bombed children
hospitals so they can do everything a
new cbs news poll shows 73 percent of
americans support a military response
only if russia attacks a nato country
but ukrainian americans fear there will
be nothing left of ukraine if the u.s
and its allies don't do more the entire
world is with ukraine and we're fighting
for democracy there are now over 9 000
u.s soldiers in poland there only to
defend the nato country as russian
military strikes get closer and closer
jennifer johnson global news washington